فكيف يذهب الباحثون من النظر إلى
دماغ هذا الرجل ورؤية
رواسب البروتين التي ساعدته على هذا
الاختلاف الجيني وأخذ ذلك ربما
في نوع من العلاج
الذي هو سؤال بريانا
واسمحوا لي أن أبدأ بالقول إن الناس
متفائلون جدًا بشأن هذه  النتائج
ولكن هناك طريق طويل لنقطعه من هذا
إلى العلاجات حيث قال لنا أحد الباحثين أن
هناك بعض الأدلة الآن فقط
وضع المزيد من الريلين وهو هذا
البروتين في الدماغ يمكن أن يساعد
وتحديداً في هذه المنطقة المعينة من
الدماغ ، فقط القيام بذلك قد يكون
مفيدًا  للأشخاص من حيث الوقاية من مرض
الزهايمر والوقاية من الخرف المبكر ،
لكني أعتقد أن هناك
جزءًا آخر للقصة وهو أن معظم
العلاجات الدوائية الموجودة
الآن بريانا مصممة لإزالة
لوحة الأميلويد ، وكما لاحظت في
الدراسة وأنا  فعلوا كذلك هؤلاء
المرضى الذين علمت من كانوا
يعملون بشكل جيد من الناحية المعرفية وكان لديهم الكثير من
اللويحات في دماغهم ، لذا
قد لا يكون التخلص من اللويحة هو
الجواب هنا الذي توقعه الناس حول
هذا الأمر لبعض الوقت ولكن هذا
دليل إضافي على  نقترح التركيز على
اللوحة ليست القصة بأكملها هنا